Let's seek the Lord together for the holiness that only comes from God.
Father, you are amazingly, beautifully, eternally
holy.
I praise you, Lord, that you are the one that all
holiness starts with and originates from.
I praise you that just like your holiness communicated
from you to the holy ground that Moses stood on
and encountered you on,
I want to encounter you. We want to see you in your holiness and the
purity of it. We want to see your holiness and the beauty
and the power and the glory of it.
I praise you, Lord, that everything you touch, everything you
possess is holy, just as you are holy.
So, oh God, would you flow to me, flow
through me, Lord. Let the holiness of God
produce in me greater and greater holiness until
everything about me is like everything
about you. I pray, oh God, that you would fill new
parts of my mind and my heart and my attitudes.
I pray that you would fill places that I don't even know
exist right now, that you would touch them and make them
holy like you are holy. Make it, Lord, to where
we shine.
I pray for the person, Lord, the person who's reading this and
listening to this, that's praying with me right now.
I pray that you would fill them so full of your holiness
that like the bush was burned and yet not consumed, they
would flame with your holiness and yet not be burned
and consumed, but be aglow with the beauty of your
holiness. I pray this in Jesus' name. Amen.
I would encourage you to continue to pray now and make your own appeal
to the Lord for the beauty of his holiness to flow into you in the areas
of your life that you need most. Let's continue in prayer.